mais nous allons accueillir l elle
mérite les applaudissements c'est
ophélie ophélie qui n'a que 13 ans et
demi ça portant un stage la halle et
demi à moi je conduis et demi mais à cet
âge là c'est très important et ce qui
est plus important pour elle c'est que
c'est une de ses premières télévisions
comme ça en public sur une chaîne
nationale
le titre de la chanson c'est poil de
carotte un rapport peut-être avec la
couleur des t-shirts non oui alors
ophélie on va encore t'applaudir et on
va te regarde et apprécié ok ophélie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as
je t'aime à perdre à elle
[Musique]
calais
non
[Musique]
les
mais moi
mon attente
voir
moi le cas
de l'est
ouais
de 40
hélas
lanester
oui
[Applaudissements]
pendant douze ans
[Musique]
ce qui suit
pendant
[Musique]
ed
moi je ne viens j'aime bien
[Musique]
tu as l'air de moody
je n'aime pas perdre
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
dans une paroisse qui sont
pour
tu peux
ton fils
pas le loup le loup garou
m
[Musique]
carottes turin
mondiale et jetaient m'appellera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vas aller de vous dire
et je t'aime à perdre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]